the gyro can experience you know what I
only thing I acts with my kids I see
actually college ain't for everybody so
I'm not gonna force college on you but
what you do owe me is a high school
diploma and you do all me the prom
because I didn't have an opportunity to
do none of that [ __ ] so all of them go
to the poor all I went to the prom I
picked that outfit and every one of them
graduated from high school you know out
my daughter was the first one in three
generation to graduate high school the
first one ever go to college and she
didn't finish but hey - my my youngest
daughter just finished criminal justice
she have associate's degree and you know
every time they do it is like I'm going
to the prom for you they graduated high
school they gave me the high school
diploma my daughter was like oh well I
just graduate from college
yo hey girl your degree you know I mean
she didn't go to her graduation she she
she didn't want to go to graduation
so she booked it she had two options so
she booked it on one day I was out of
town but she gret she's my first child I
graduated college and I look back Here I
am with the 8th grade education on GED
and I was able to keep my kids from
going on the road that I went down and
you know most most most kids try to make
their parents proud I try to make my
kids proud to let them know it's not
about how you start is about how you
finish you know I had to I had to meet
to my oldest daughter and I said Johnson
front house school and I you know I had
to wake her at one time and I said I
want to apologize for being such a
horrible mom in the beginning but I was
[ __ ] 14 you know she was in housing
where they had shootout at she saw me
sell drugs in front of her school I said
I've made a lot of [ __ ] mistakes but
I'm sorry because I did what everybody
else was doing in my community trying to
survive and that was one of the hardest
thing as a parent because a lot of
parents hi you know their past when they
kid but I I literally went to my
daughter and I you know cuz she hated me
Joe she [ __ ] hated me she's like why
do you have to sell drugs in front of my
school
because I was here first [ __ ] but you
know who I think you know we we have we
have a relationship now you know and
then I went out to jail and I missed her
going to kindergarten and then I grew up
in a community where he was gay
something was wrong with you you know my
daughter she gets [ __ ] she eat
everything in Atlanta she packed man
with the [ __ ] so I had to deal with
that too because she ran out for a while
when she when she wouldn't you know when
I she didn't want to tell me she was gay
because I mean I had this thing where if
you were gay with some roach I [ __ ]
hated gay women and I used to say this
on stage when I say white man when you
when you when you hate [ __ ] that's a
good chance your white daughter gonna
come home with a big big [ __ ]
it went over your foot my daughter came
home and she was gay and it opened my
[ __ ] world to the gay community and
now like I don't know when my daughter
came out of someone's life you must be
ashamed that your daughter's guest on
[ __ ] your daughter's a hole so your
daughter gonna take way more dicks they
my daughter do okay I love my daughter I
love all of my kids and and I told
Ashley that's her name I said it's not
about I had to learn it's not about your
sexuality do what make you happy and I
will support you to the end as long as
you happen because you saw your daddy
stomped my face and shoot me and
mistreat me so if we wanna do what makes
you happy just don't do drugs [ __ ]
but do what make you happy what what
made you not like gay women before that
cuz I was raising black community if he
was gay you know we're the biggest
[ __ ] black people who would
throw up a gay child I tell you
something wrong which we talk to hate
you know especially that old-school
black community that's why so you know
people you know why is that
I don't know Joe that's just how he was
raised the black church drilling in your
head you know if you gay you going to
hell and you know you're Martin so what
happens with gay people in the bar
community a lot of them leave and never
come back back in the day a lot of them
wait
say you know they [ __ ] mental problems
I don't know like I didn't I don't
remember gay uncle anybody so but you
know I know we at the black community
you have to hide you had to hide making
those days so I was taught if he was gay
it would you was it was something wrong
with you and when my daughter came out
to be gay
it opened my [ __ ] world up and I was
like do I judge my daughter over
sexuality or do I love my child because
it's my [ __ ] child and I remember not
seeing her for three years she just
running [ __ ] dropped out of college just
go home state to state damn near
homeless a lot on be homeless
and I said look Ashley I said are you
gay I just want to hear it for myself
she was like yes ma'am
that's what come on homey puss in
Atlanta's Jesus and my child came home
and we built a relationship and I and
you know I was wrong because she heard
how I talked about gay people in house
it's almost like when you hear your
review of you why didn't hear your
parents I was [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] in
there then you want to know why is every
time I dig you get curious can you go
outside and like it ain't what you think
it is so when she came out and you know
she when she came out he opened my room
and I'm happy I'm happy for my baby
night la about my daughter will eat the
[ __ ] out you she would dick you down
grandma but she happy doing this what is
all about you know all you can ask Miss
a honking that all I X is that she get a
[ __ ] they treat her right that she's a
hole right now but you know new girl
every six my with his new girl she got
she been sticking a little fun along I
like the last girlfriend who he saw
Bigfoot but she got rid of Bigfoot if
she was a boy she to play professionally
bass club big ol feet but I liked her a
lot a new girlfriend she growing on me
so but it's all about being happy